metro police are responding to the
derrick chauvin trial
and verdict tonight they call this
really a crucial moment for law
enforcement agencies all across the
country
orco mana joining us live from metro
police headquarters
with more on what those police had to
say
brian metro police say they do not
tolerate the actions derek chauvin took
last summer
and they believe the jury held him
accountable metro
also making it clear that there is no
room for that kind of conduct
within their department metro
undersheriff christopher darcy
says the department has worked hard to
create an environment that does not
allow officers
to behave the way chauvin did and metro
wants to be at the forefront of making
improvements
under sheriff darcy says the police have
built relationships with faith-based
partners and community groups
and even their critics to make important
policy changes
those include new use of force tactics
and enhanced de-escalation training
and the death of george floyd and the
trial of derrick chauvin is another
reminder that there is still work to do
it gives us an opportunity to look
inward and look at other policies and
think
is there some other area maybe where
we're not looking at that we can make
those changes
so i think in order to be a good
organization you have to be continually
changing right continuing to adapt
to change and to meet the needs of the
community
metro says as groups potentially
gathered tonight across las vegas
they also want to make it clear that
they stand with those people
but that they want everything to remain
peaceful reporting live from metro
headquarters tonight orco mana 8 news
now